South Koreans head to the polls in April
to elect a new 300 member legislature
among the candidates will be a
high-level defector from North Korea
recruited by South Korea's new
conservative bloc taeyoung ho has
visited this venue the Seoul foreign
correspondents club before following his
defection the former North Korean deputy
ambassador to the United Kingdom
denounced the North Korean leadership
and Kim jong-un and suggested the
current liberal South Korean government
was wasting its time in its peacemaking
efforts a said he was inspired to run
because he wants to protect the human
rights of North Koreans after two recent
defectors suspected murderers were
repatriated by the South Korean
government I'm absolutely sure that one
day Korea will be united and if real I
do not get a gain who will go first
North Korea
they also said he would work for North
Koreans in the south to give them better
educational opportunities to lead a
unified Korea if someone is shouting in
the river saved me to the people or to
the past biased
Malou you know bring or law whether you
can save these people or not we lose
judge whether he is criminal or no if he
is criminal than Balu you know give up
your saving efforts and let them die in
the river
no Tay has said he believes the Kim
jong-un regime days are numbered in
favours denuclearization before
engagement with Pyongyang
if I do get elected I believe that there
needs to be a very clear clause in South
Korean law that declares how cooperation
between the north and south can be
resumed with denuclearization
so that North Korean policy does not go
back and forth according to politics
some long-standing lawmakers of the
Liberal Democratic Party questioned the
motivations behind his candidacy hey
young who likes to show off in public
and so he decided to run for Congress
with the Conservatives and they enticed
mr. Tay to increase right wing power
in South Korea and create an anti North
Korea anti piece atmosphere on the
Korean Peninsula Tay has spoken little
of South Korean issues and his newly
formed a United Future party still
hasn't announced for which district he
plans to run